bonsoir à tous cet étal géo il ya bien
longtemps le jeune paul belmondo qui
allait devenir sculpteur et peintre
suivait dans les coulisses d'un théâtre
le célèbre jacques copeau puis à un
moment quelqu'un aviez belmondo alors
jacques copeau s'est tourné vers le
jeune homme et lui a dit belmondo voilà
un nom qui serait splendide pour un
comédien et bien jacques copeau avait
raison sauf que ce n'est pas paul
belmondo mais son fils jean paul né en
1933 qui allait devenir le le comédien
acteur de théâtre et de cinéma que nous
aimons beaucoup aient été tués dont on
peut dire aujourd'hui près qu'il a on va
fêter bientôt 40 ans de carrière sauf
que je fais évidemment commencé sa
carrière à une date très important c'est
à dire à bout de souffle de godard à
bout de souffle qui a été tourné en 59
et que nous avons pu voir en 68 jeux
combien ça fait bientôt jean paul
belmondo bonsoir ça fait donc bientôt 40
ans que vous entrez évidemment d'une
manière intermittente épisodique mais
vous entrez dans la vie de millions de
français il ya là donc une une confiance
une fidélité réciproque est-ce que 40
ans après vous ce que vous êtes comment
diable celle cette confiance ça vous
remplit de fierté de bonheur maintenant
un peu de nostalgie au gain finalement
au bout du compte ça vous laisse tout ça
un peu froid en annonçant les spas froid
loin de là non ça me donne beaucoup de
bonheur est très content qu au bout de
tant d'années les gens aient encore
envie d'aller boire et moi j'ai toujours
cette envie de monter sur les planches
ou d'être devant une caméra je crois que
le jour où je n'aurai plus cette envie
je partirai mais je ne la sens pas venir
pour le moment
qu'est-ce que plus difficile c'est
rester en haut de la fiche avec des
grosses lettres ou entrer dans l'oeuf
dans la fiche mais mon l'être même petit
minuscule mais je crois que oui le plus
difficile c'est de rentrer dans cet
avantage parce que c'est pas facile de
une sorte de deux murs au début on se
demande comment je vais pouvoir passer
et moi pendant des années j'étais en
tout petit tout petit dans la fiche
puisque
c'est normal et je vais pendant très
longtemps théâtre des petits rôles dans
des petits théâtres oui mais est-ce que
vous vous souvenez de la première
affiche où il ya eu votre nom en tout
petit alors voyez très bien c'est vrai
au théâtre de la huchette jouer loriana
sera vengé on était dix huit en scène
dont il y avait dix huit petits n'ont
marqué très très petit sur la fiche de
la huchette et il devait avoir par soir
7 8 spectateurs sont remontées un peu
plus que j'ai débuté comme ça 21 mais
est-ce que vous avez gardé beaucoup de
souvenirs de kayes rcd avait gardé des
affiches des lettres des contrats des cd
moi je n'ai pas gardé beaucoup mais il
ya des gens qui est très gentil momomo
front des chaumes à faire des des
affiches
j'ai gardé un contrat j'ai un contrat où
j'avais six francs de l'époque par soir
les j'ai gardé oui parce que ça c'était
un contrat au théâtre michel mais cette
affiche que vous évoquiez vous l'avez
oui j'ai
celle aussi des la gaîté montparnasse si
vous jouez crinolines et guéri mais
quand même parce que vraiment vous vos
débuts si vous avez joué le prince
charmant dans la belle au bois dormant
et là vous n'aviez que
vous aviez que 17 après charles n'était
pas le prince charmant ah bon et c'est
une tournée dans les hôpitaux de paris
allait saper d'adrar y ait pas d affiche
non mais en revanche je vois quand 51
vous avez joué mon ami le cambrioleur de
d'andrea gay avec guy bedos qui est vrai
si jeune que vous c'est une tournée
d'été amélie-les-bains des affiches oui
a eu des achats voilà c'est la première
alors ça c'est vraiment la première à
ben oui un breguet envoyées à la mairie
mais aussi alors on a joué
amélie-les-bains manager beaucoup
d'endroits aussi et on joue et même un
soir on a joué dans un garage et donc il
y avait des spectateurs professionnels
les gens paient et pendant qu'on joue et
un type qui est venir enlever sa voiture
et c'était des époques on a joué et
aussi avec bedos donc cette tournée a
uni ses de prison plus mal puisque un
soir justement à amélie les bains le
jeune premier avait tendance à boire et
il était saoul et la première scène il a
balancé toute la pièce de verre qui l'a
dit la fin donc ça s'est arrêté au bout
d'une demi heure elle directeur des
théâtres et vieillit c'est très amusant
ce lever de rideau qu'est-ce que vous ne
jouez après y avait rien et cela alors
bedos a raconté les histoires et bois à
l'époque j'ai limité roger nicolas en
allemand c'est comme ça et là on est
parti on est rentrés tous les deux sur
un camion de farine qui a remonté sur
paris et moi j'ai dit je me présente au
conservatoire c'est sûr su te continuer
bedos a dit pareil et
et si on est recalé on arrête j'étais
reçus j'ai continué la terre calella
continue aussi a bien fait bon alors
pour comme on dit parce que vous êtes un
grand sportif et
puisque moi bien que j'aime beaucoup le
sport donc comme on dit dans la boxe où
le football on va se mettre en jambes un
peu au début bien que la perçoit que
vous n'avez pas besoin et donc je vous
proposais des des images des images de
donc assez lointaine parce que d'actes
août d'avant à bout de souffle parce que
je prends vraiment à bout de souffle
c'est ça qui vous imposer quand même
bien sûr les dix matches d'avant oui
d'avant et alors évidemment qu'ils sont
peu connus alors sauf erreur c'est on va
voir des images du premier film dans
lequel vous avez tourné il s'intitule
les comme les copains du dimanche il est
si est signée henry eisner alors il date
de 1956 donc trois ans avant un bout de
souffle et alors vous jouez le rôle d'un
jeune ouvrier qui avec ses camarades
dans un aéroclub sont en train de
rafistoler un avion et ça c'est la scène
de l'anniversaire
et qui ont pas bougé tu sais
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils pas
l'image
un anniversaire ou savagnier de l'air
bon anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
pour faire sa ba bilan à la tête que tu
fais mais pourquoi tu attends faire
alors de mado jacqueline
c'est la première fois quand c'est ton
anniversaire comme ça
pourquoi le décret dit alors cette
personne n'est venu en bateau
moi
là c'est yves deniaud radio il y avait
aussi pris d'assaut qui jouait marca ce
jeudi à berthod leur dise noël oui alors
d'abord une chose c'est que vous avez 23
ans mais vous en faites 17 18 c'est
incroyable ce que vous faites jeunes
c'est inouï et puis ça c'est un film
c'est un film militant
oui il était produit par la cgt
sinon c'est pas si gp et ce qui est plus
grave c'est que bon été payés
au pourcentage et le film n'est jamais
sorti oui
je n'avais rien toucher le film est
sorti bien après à bout de souffle
encore oui j'ai été connais et ils l'ont
ils en ont profité pour le sortir mon
ami rue aucun succès oui mais il passait
dans les comités d'entreprise à cédrika
mais beaucoup de gens finalement la
bévue oui mais mes deux évidemment
gratuitement gratuitement et clé vous
savez comment je les fait se fit non et
je suis souvent je venais de passer mes
concours de conservatoire et nous étions
dans la région avec des copains et on
joue au football avec une valise en
carton et il y assure henri eisner qui
était avec a fait ce seul film
d'ailleurs résumé rien feydeau et m'a
dit voilà je fais un film où kris
furillo faire cela et je me suis
retrouvé là avec un tas de gens ya
piccoli aussi des donc un petit rôle un
tas de gens étaient dangereux dans ce
film alors autre image lointaine celle
ci alors c'est une image de télévision
c'était en 1957 donc toujours avoir à
bout de souffle la grande émission de
l'époque c'était évidemment les trente
six chandelles de jean nohain et alors
le jean marais jean marais qui venait de
reprendre la pièce de george bernard
shaw antoine et cléopâtre était venu
comme on dit aujourd'hui faire la
promotion de la pièce dans l'émission de
jean nohain et alors jean marais était
évidemment il ya dix ans césar et toute
la troupe étaient venus costumés alors
il y présente un à un comme ça jusqu'à
et monsieur devilder
et le centurion
le clip éternelle de l'adjudant et
monsieur jean paul belmondo
qui est le légionnaire romain de
deuxième classe
[Musique]
oui et l'autre disait vous avez beaucoup
de talent et jean marais a toujours dit
qu'il avait toujours pressenti votre
votre qui l'avait vu au talent il
pressenti votre grande carrière mais oui
écouter jean marc était été formidables
parce que c'était une énorme peut-être
là turati des normes est nette mais à
l'époque c'était il est énorme et il
était très très gentil avec nous et moi
je jouais c'est la sentinelle peureuse
exactement je suis un type qui empêchait
demande de passer qui file à vos égaux
donc déjà un contre-emploi un
contre-emploi les allées et marées le
soir nous avec bernard noël nous
regarder jouer est toujours une dizaine
tu ferais une carrière mais
alors dans la même pièce d'ailleurs il y
avait jacques perrin qui avait 24 buts
oui enfin non pas c'est vous qui avez 24
ans et là encore
n'en
faut et vous avez joué j'ai remarqué
beaucoup de rôle de sentinelle de garde
de soldats au cm2 on à venir oui
beaucoup l'un je partais beaucoup comme
ça ça et où le bon copain du jeune
premier mais j'ai fait beaucoup de
gardes coup de sentinelle les meubles en
fait une femme avec une femme à part une
pièce d'henri monier à la gaîté
montparnasse je jouais à crinolines et
guillotine les plusieurs sketches de
monier et à un moment donné avec jean
martin page at jean-martin l'acteur et
un moment donné on faisait deux
concierges et ce qui était drôle c'est
qu'à côté il y avait encore le casino de
montparnasse en garde les petites femmes
nues et la pièce n'avait pas un énorme
succès on n'a pas beaucoup de
spectateurs et le samedi ceux qui
pouvaient pas rentrer pour voir les
petites femmes nues vous et crinolines
et guillotiné rentrer là dedans voyons
voir qu'ils allaient voir des femmes et
et voyez
je parlais de soul de poison et le
succès alors voit encore des images
lointaine et alors cela elles sont
désopilantes mais involontairement un
avant à bout de souffle vous avez tourné
dans le premier film de jean luc godard
qui est un court métrage qui s'intitule
charlotte et son jules et tournait
d'ailleurs de dents dans sa chambre et
donc on va voir des images c'est bien
jean paul belmondo que vous allez voir
mais la voix vous allez entendre ce
n'est pas celle de jean paul belmondo
celle accent vaudois de gens lui de jean
luc godard
tu veux absolument faire du cinéma il ya
douze mille autres types avec qui aller
coucher peut d'ailleurs pourquoi faire
du cinéma je trouve ça déshonorant
déshonorant et démodé
c'est vrai qu'est ce que c'est le cinéma
une grosse tête en train de faire des
grimaces dans une petite salle
il faut être con pour eux mais ça mais
si je sais ce que je dis le cinéma c'est
un art illusoire
le roman la peinture d'accord ne pas
cinéma
c'est formidable c'est parce que déjà on
voit le talent provocateur de de godard
et pourquoi veux mon dieu et vous
affublez de savoir chercher expliqué
quand j'ai fait ce court métrage
j'ai joué en même temps une pièce qui
s'appelait oscar fameuse carte saïd
pierre mondy et un jour j'ai rencontré
godard qui m'a demandé comme ça je ne
connaissais pas ce que vous voyez dans
la rue saint-benoît bizarre toujours mal
rasé et oui un jour une pièce quand vous
voulez faire du cinéma je suis non pas
du tout et puis non pas avec ma femme et
elle me dit moi
ici t'emmerde tu mettras coûte par
ailleurs les pieds tout de suite en
lâchant pas ce qu'il dit je vais vous
donner 500 francs si vous venez dans ma
chambre et mon tour je suis dit qu'est
ce que
je suis arrivé d'objets il n'y avait
rien il n'y avait pas de texte et il me
souffler le texte il dit alors dit lui
s'avère alors tu disais ça bon et puis
je pars et pim du bonbon servira pour le
synchroniser et en je suis rappelé en
algérie donc je barre et j'étais en
algérie et godard may cry voilà il ya
une opportunité pour que ce film ne
sorte si tu me laisses doublé il peut
sortir alors j'ai dit oui pas il n'y a
pas de problème donc le film est sorti
avec sa voix et après quand je suis
revenue l'algérie il y avait becker le
père jacky préparer un film il a vu ce
court métrage l'a dit oui ce garçon est
bien mais il a une voix épouvantable et
m'a pris oui donc j'ai pas voulu qu'on
leur double parce que je pense qu'il
fallait que ça reste assez mais c'est un
hybride formidable quand même et oui
c'est un belmondo avec la voix de godard
c'est peut-être mieux que le la le corps
de godard et la voix de belmondo oui
c'est une chose quand même assez bizarre
puis je crois que c'est un peu le texte
est un petit peu le brouillon d'aboutir
dans les rapports avec alcool est alors
toujours dans les images d'autrefois
voici le seul spectacle que vous ayez
fait pour la télé meilleur pour la
télévision c'était en 1959 donc c'est
entre d'ailleurs vous aviez déjà tourné
à bout de souffle mais il est le fils
mais placer encore sorti donc c'est
claude barma qui vous a repéré il faut
bien le dire là aussi comme tout le
monde et qui vous a proposé de jouer
dans les trois mousquetaires à la
télévision mais il n'a pas proposé un
petit rôle et vous a proposé tout
simplement le rôle de d'artagnan bah oui
d'ailleurs capter m'a appelé aussi bas
et m'a convoqué et et bon j'ai cru qu'il
m'appelait pour plancher parce qu'à
l'époque sur les comics et mode et la
distribution voilà il ya intel intel et
puis plancher crb rire ça y est je fais
le garde si spéciale derrière c'est pas
moi qui vais tuer plancher et il m'a
annoncé d'artagnan à je suis tombé
parfait voici un extrait
alors je le dis tout de suite au des
spectacles c'était en direct en direct
en direct donc combien trois semaines de
répétition avant oui à peine trois
semaines en répétition pas dans les
décors dans le décor ont répété le jour
même dans le décor et c'est comme ça
principe à peut-être un peu long mais
chez iga sommet un figurant comme ça
sans faire exprès parce que on répétait
toujours ce descendant de la somme est
qu un tabouret et le soir
de la pièce on dirait alors même dit
alors vas-y 1 parce que là il est en
balsa le truc ça a explosé ya pas de
travail pas françois bayrou a les yeux
du mec battant les red parties truquées
et tout en continuant bat avec les
autres mais c'est mon dieu je les tue et
il était à l'hôpital quand même le pense
alors on va voir une scène donc toujours
sa direction claude barma avec jean
chevrier qui jouent et atos daniel
sorano porthos et hubert noël aramis
maintenant que vous êtes tous réunis
permettez moi de vous faire mes excuses
ben vous ne comprenez pas messieurs je
m'excuse d'une seule chose c'est de ne
pouvoir payer ma dette à tous trois en
effet monsieur atos a le droit de me
tuer le premier ce qui ôte beaucoup de
valeur votre créance monsieur porthos et
rend la vôtre à peu près nulles monsieur
aramis je risque de faire banqueroute à
l'un de vous a deux peut-être voilà de
quoi je m'excusais rien de cela
maintenant messieurs
quand vous voudrez
[Musique]
c'est un bon souvenir à très bon
souvenir c'est un souvenir formidable
parce que d'abord vous devez la
brochette d'acteurs et avait donc sont
formés très bien c'était des parties de
rigolade et puis bon il avait la
sensation du direct était exsangue vous
connais vous pas recommencer ou de
refuser de faire la télévision vous fier
de jouer en effet dès la fiction de la
télévision pourquoi vous savez pourquoi
pas ce que j'ai fait beaucoup de cinéma
non non non non non non vous avez
toujours dédaigner la télévision de la
non écoute et si vous avez la télévision
la télévision c'est la mort des acteurs
de cinéma faisait déclaré ça
j'étais jeune oui les genoux et non
halal à des pourparlers sérieusement
c'est vrai j'ai refusé pendant des
années de faire de la télé je ne voulais
faire que du cinéma ou du théâtre mais
pourquoi aujourd'hui nous ne feriez vous
pas la télévision je sais pas peut-être
j'en ferais maintenant avec l'âge oui on
réfléchit sans regarder deux par dieu et
a fait un triomphe dans monte cristo il
garde et pierre arditi non mais vous
savez quoi qui est l'évolution aussi
c puis la même chose qu'à cette époque
maintenant le ya un tas de films qu'on
ne peut plus faire et qu'on peut faire à
la télévision vous parlez du comte de
monte cristo vous ne pouvez pas le faire
au cinéma les en direct ça a été dur win
avait maintenu ses c'est ça coûterait
beaucoup trop cher et le rendement ne
serait pas assurée alors qu'à la
télévision on peut le faire très très
bien
donc cela change aussi donc si france 2
ou france 3 vous propose téléfilm
vraiment un frein très bon scénario d
achat vous êtes prêt à accepter oui si
c'est une grande
chose vous êtes prêts oui je suis prêt à
laisser à nos critères par exemple oui
mais oui non vous donnera pas d'artagnan
[Rires]
alors encore des images étonnantes est
la date de 1960 donc alors l'année d' à
bout de souffle mais là je vais
m'adresser aux téléspectateurs dans quel
film jean paul belmondo at il tourné
avec brigitte bardot regardez cette
scène entre deux c'est très très chaud
une patate était chouette quand même je
peux monter
à bord il ya des i puis de toute façon
quoi
ça me déplaît
avec toi c'est pas pareil toi tu fais
sérieux c'est sérieux minot je t'aime
si tous les défauts de la terre mais je
t'aime pour devant
tu voudrais
j'aime bien tout j'aime bien quand même
aussi
alors réponse dans quel film
c'est un laissé pour la vérité je
n'avais jamais tourné non si j'avais
tourné avec ben oui c'est curieux là
j'ai pas été pris
alors donc c'était un essai aps de
clouzot pour la musau voilà pour la
vérité et puis elle raconté eh bien j'ai
je vais vous dire la vérité pourquoi je
l'ait pas fait parce que je n'ai pas
l'oreille musicale du tout d'un handicap
surnom du cap et de ce côté là et
j'avais dit à clouzot quand ils vont
faire les bouts d'essai il m'a dit c'est
un chef d'orchestre je dis c'est pas
possible
je suis incapable de battre avec moi
vous y arriverez n'y a pas de problème
mais fait faire les bouts d'essai avec
brigitte bardot c'est le fait ça avec
d'autres un oui on le lay a beaucoup qui
ont passé toute la journée en a on était
bonne quinzaine à y aller a dit
seine-saint-denis s'était et ça c'était
le côté agréable et c est après fallait
passer à la baguette et alors là vous
mettez vous avez retenu oui et puis
alors on est arrivé à sa fille alors la
falaise d'entendants pourrait bien vous
voyez vous pouvez unis ça s'arrête là l
heure après il avait été impossible et
il a fermé la porte à clef il voulait
vraiment me forcer à prendre la musique
et dans la moi je me suis énervé je lis
ici vous voudrez pas la pause la foule
par terre donc ma prestation s'il
arrêtait là il faut dire aussi que vous
vouliez jouer avec jeanne moreau dans
monte je l'avais g ces deux bouts
d'essai j'ai fait un bout d'essai aussi
avec eric moreau à la même époque et
justement clouzot avait des mais vous
n'allez pas les tournées dans suivent
vous détournez là dedans et puis bon bah
c'est sami frey qui
vous avait d'ailleurs fait beaucoup de
deux bouts d'essai vous avez fait
d'aider des auditions donné beaucoup au
théâtre et au cinéma
oui mais rarement pris j'ai rarement
pris
lors des bourses à lyon il ya
vingt-trois jeunes du conservatoire qui
sont venus vous vous écoutez vous vous
applaudir et est requise à grands pas et
qu à jouer alors par exemple louis malle
vous a préféré georges poujouly dans
l'ascenseur pour l'échafaud et marcel
carné vous a préféré laurent terzieff
pour les tricheurs reversait nous a
préféré pierre vaneck pour bar donner
aux enfants par parenthèse quand même
trois bons il n'y a pas de déshonneur il
n'y a pas de désolation surtout avec
tertiaire vont s'y trouvaient souvent
avec laurent sur des bouts d'essai où on
n'était pas pris et là on s'est
retrouvés tous les deux en finale et
donc j'étais très content que ce soit un
ou deux qui le fasse et puis je pense
que c'était plus pour lui que pour moi
je crois que notre seul regret c'est de
ne pas avoir tourné voyage au bout de la
nuit de céline oui je vous dirais
endettement qui en a deux il ya
l'étranger de camus aussi je devais
faire moi une époque avec boloni et
vi compte et ça c'est pas monter tout de
suite et visconti lui a repris les
droits et ap le film mais le voyage au
bout de la nuit ça s'éteint c'est mon
anglais oui mais sauf qu'il n'a jamais
été fait il n'a jamais été fait j'espère
qui sera fait un jour mais c'était vrai
qu'il y aurait eu le scénario et
dialogues d'audiard et j'ai mise en
scène de godard vraiment c'était le
projet wii pensée conseillé par pierrot
le fou oui bon on espérait tous que ça
allait à bout des années mais vous êtes
un grand lecteur de céline oui oui oui
beaucoup céline quels sont les écrivains
crise et que vous appréciez en dehors de
ces lignes vous c'est moi je lis un peu
tout je vais pas vous dire
faire un des bateaux dire si untel untel
untel gély j'aime beaucoup les
biographies aussi j'en lis beaucoup et
il ya un auteur qui est en même temps
diallo disque dont j'ai relu l'hyper
d'hermance et audiard qui va bouleverser
donc voyez chevet un petit peu même pas
oublier les grues et les autos ce que
j'ai à vous dire l'écart mais de
léautaud ça des choses que j'adore
souvenirs
douloureux mais votre mère est morte
s'il n'ya pas très longtemps et je crois
qu'elle était aveugle à la fin de ses
jours et vous lui faisait la lecture oui
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous lisiez
mais justement j'avais des allées b
beaucoup les autos parce que comme que
je me rappelle quand on était jeunes à
la maison il y avait les entretiens avec
du maillet avec les autos et parlait
très friands de sa écouté beaucoup ça et
après donc et je lui religion du maniema
les mâles et mal je ne verrai pas du
mayet mari et elle aimait elle aimait
beaucoup des biographies beaucoup de
biographies de simono des grands acteurs
de danseuse
puis des oeuvres qu'elle avait envie de
tester gallezot cds qui connaît bien la
bid belmondo alors je n'ai aucun mérite
parce que toutes mes informations je les
ai puisé dans cette biographie qui est
signée philippe durand qui est sortie il
ya cinq ans et qui robert laffont
l'éditeur remet en vente avec deux
nouveaux chapitres but qui raconte les
cinq dernières années depuis
l'apparition du livre et c'est un
ouvrage qui est qui est très riche en
informations en inde dote en témoignage
et l excellent travail
d'enquêteur et puis en plus elle est
très agréable à lire et du début à la
fin et je pense que tous les gens qui
vous aiment en tout cas qui vous
admirent peuvent se procurer ce livre
parce qu'ils apprendront évidemment
mille choses je crois oui comme moi je
les fais est ce qu'on peut dire que de
tous les pays étrangers c'est l'italie
qui est probablement votre préférée je
suppose oui parce que l'italie bon chez
les origines italiennes puisque ma grand
mère et mon grand père paternel était
italien et puis j'ai fait beaucoup de
films l'italie attendait sur vos
origines vous allez un peu vite donc
c'est votre âge et votre grand père qui
a quitté l'italie oui c'est ça venir
forgeron alger en général j'essaie
s'arrêteront alger mais une autre
branche de la famille qui a quitté
l'italie pour les états unis pour les
états unis hors série qu'est ce que vous
avez des nouvelles de cette baie est
cotée sur des états unis un jour je
tournais avec lellouche
à la new orleans et est arrivé un série
tôt parce que d'écouter ma grand mère
s'appelait série tôt et il est arrivé
par les l'italo-américain alors n'a été
dîner ensemble donc on a eu beaucoup de
mal à ce qu'on pense et il était en face
de moi il faisait tout est belle at il
dit à jean paul besset ici et bella
teaching tous leurs parce que c'est
comme ça et alors qu'on ne sait jamais
revu
et puis vous aviez mais parmi mes vos
aïeux vous avez une femme qui était une
grande danseuse série théorique
auquel année là c'était là il ya quand
même voilà alors et puis donc à rien et
alice est vrai que sa tournée à la suite
cinq ou six films
et vous avez tenus dans vos bras les
grandes stars italiennes des années 60
c'est à dire excusez du peu gina
lollobrigida sophia loren et claudia
cardinale
oui c'est vrai et oui et je vous aime
était amoureux d'elle amoureux d'elle
oui les films oui oui non mais dans la
vie je parle non j'étais mariée or
quel menteur
non mais vous savez ce qui était fort
béda vous parler de ces femmes là accor
non mais de deux choses l'une où elle
était moins séduisante révèle où vous
étiez
vous n'etes est quand même un sérieux
non mais je pensais que vous étiez
beaucoup plus vulnérable que ça quand
même pardon je suis très dur
non mais c'est ce qui est drôle avec
paris up sophia loren dis je je voyais
dans les magazines c'est est inconnue
tue joué par au théâtre et comme tous
les acteurs on acheter si des mondes à
l'épaule dans ces nouveaux employés
lollobrigida ça faisait rire et sophia
loren et du jour au lendemain ou j'ai
fait à bout de souffle je me retrouve à
rome et je tourne avec sophia loren
c'est impressionné de voir cette femme
superbe et tous et dès le premier jour
j'étais dans ses bras et j'ai dû rouler
un patin de première c'était incroyable
comme avec bardot oui comec bardot ou
d'entrée est de 6 cas là vous allez
m'entendre embrasser tout y était un pas
6 heures du matin
voilà si c'est la dolce vita
le vrai coupable d'un mode d'un homme
que vous avez beaucoup c'est votre père
paul belmondo avec cette tradition des
pôles votre fille s'appelle paul il y
avait lui même il a un fils qui
s'appelle charles henri là il a cassé la
tradition instaurée au gabon il ya plus
d'un an il a cassé le
pourquoi cette tradition des pôles dans
toute la famille qui remonte jusqu'à
saint paul ii une pauvre
bon alors un jour vous avez dit à votre
père qu'ils rappellent et donc sculpteur
et peintre je lui avais dit ben non moi
j'ai eu avant de venir tous les acteurs
dédiés j'ai envie de devenir clown et
curieusement il n'a pas été très surpris
non parce que vous savez
ma mère aimait beaucoup le cirque et
elle nous emmenaient avec mon frère
beaucoup au cirque et j'étais fasciné
par les clowns les trapézistes et moi je
faisais avec les copains 12 ans tout ça
je suis remontée des petits des petits
numéros de clowns mon père vous savez
quand je lui ai dit que je voulais être
clown à un moment donné ils étaient très
contents parce que
je viens de boxer footballeur qui
l'effrayait plus que
que ça donc je restais des dents dans le
spectacle vous savez des clones à
l'époque qui avait grog et rome c'était
à cet énoncé des très grands artistes
enfin il est bien là comme eux dans
monsieur paul belmondo votre rapport
vous ramener de l'école de hisser des
notes absolument épouvantable vous fait
virer des boîtes à bachelot fait vie
après vous allez vous faire virer virer
d'une entreprise fait virer des musiques
au vide et vidé des théâtres mais c'est
incroyable quand même c'était impossible
à vie et lui il accepte toujours oui
mais j'ai la chance vous c'est justement
d'avoir des parents très tolérant parce
que ma mère aussi été formidables parce
que
on tirait de partout des écoles pendant
bon
là-bas que j'ai fait c'était une boîte à
bateaux l'école pascal et les types le
disais à ma mère bas on le garde parce
que c'est un bon gardien de but mais
enfin maintenant il arrive à un certain
âge pourrait quand même qu'ils seront là
et c'est là où je suis parti au père
d'un ami qui avait une usine de joie des
coupés ils à dire mon père on va le
mettre au paquet appris à faire les
paquets à faire mais pas que lui a
préféré au bout de six mois je savais
toujours pas faire un paquet il a appelé
mon père a dit on peut vraiment y être
conférés c'est là où mon père m'a dit m
enfin le multi qu'est ce que tu veux
fait et j'ai dit je voudrais intacte
est-ce que vous avez été aussi
perfectionniste que l'été votre père
dans son art j'essaye de l'être mais ils
étaient d'une perfection incroyable que
j'ai jamais vues jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie il s'agit toujours retenu ça le
travail et la perfection un buste pour
lui n'était jamais fini d'avoir des
idées voir des images de paul belmondo
en train justement de sculpter les voir
qu'il a beaucoup aidés ils sont réalisés
arrête le buste un moment donné
il paraît qu'avec votre frère vous
fréquentez beaucoup le l'atelier de
votre père oui mais c'est à dire alors
là en toute honnêteté c'était pas
tellement pour voir sculpté c'est trop
clean pour voir les dames venus et
d'amener avait assuré commun
et envoyez-la le vrai bretagne mais il
vous laisser entrer ah oui oui
mais pensez vraiment con et loire
sculpté ah bon
on lui disait pas bien voir les modèles
comme
et lola moyens il m'a dit ce qui m'a été
souvent charles trenet c'est qu'il
laisse faire auprès des modèles et la
voici le but ça vous connaissez
présentait bien sûr c'est ça c'est
charles despiau tendance l'élément
sculpteur cutter qui était le maître de
l'acquérir
maître de mon père et qui était mon père
qui était votre parent alors on dit deux
mots sur le conservatoire parce que
parce que quand même sorti du
conservatoire sans aucun prix avec des
quelques malheureuses accessible est ce
pour cela que depuis au fond un peu vexé
vous refuser de recevoir des molières
des césars et autres répond mais c'est
tout à fait ça j'ai expliqué mon cas
français j'étais vraiment quand vous
disiez qu'il était encore j'étais encore
parce que à l'époque - j'ai commencé par
entrer comme auditeur c'est à dire que
j'avais droit d'écouter mais j'ai pas de
passé s'était déjà dit oui nul après
j'ai été choisi en prenez les moins bons
c'était nouveaux professeurs qui les
avait donc j'étais classé dans les moins
bons me suis retrouvé chez pierre dux
qui était atterré de m'avoir comme élève
et quand j'étais auditeur d'ailleurs n'a
été mis en ligne avec trois acteurs il y
avait toute la classe et simmons mais
regardez mais regardez comme ils sont
les mets ça partait mal et après si nous
récupère et moi je jouais des emplois de
jouer du xxe fin je jouais j'essayais il
faut briser scapin dans ces arbres bazot
et quand je passais il était atterré
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise je sais par où nous avez fait
c'est ce vers faut donc on avait des
rapports très dur et quand j'ai passé
les concours de conservatoire je n'ai
pas eu ce prix j'ai eu un second
accessit est excessivement rare vous
savez il y en a très peu on va faire un
club d'ailleurs parce que c'est cela
c'est la pire des choses surtout en
dernière année et un rappel deux
premiers axes et oui mais attendez vous
a été porté en triomphe par trois de vos
camarades à l'arrière et un bras
d'honneur c'était dominique rose en
berne à revoir un génie chez vous et
vous vous avez fait un bras d'honneur au
jury voilà avec normalement sur un
terrain de football un bras d'honneur
aux halles arbitre vous avez un carton
rouge il vous êtes exclu pendant
quelques régions carton rouge bien parce
que
je suis partie des conservateurs ça
s'est arrêté là fête est finie oui mais
vous savez je vous racontais une très
belle histoire j'avais un prophète happe
redux a donné sa démission et j'ai eu
henri rolland qui était un fou de
l'addiction qui parlait vraiment comme
ça et qui était un très grand acteur et
quand j'ai fait mon bras d'honneur après
il y avait tout un tas de gens pour
répondre et lui il est arrivé il m'a dit
le professeur
ne l'approuvent pas mais l'homme se dit
bravo
mais vous êtes très populaire au
conservatoire vrai très populaire parce
que parce que vous savez mais pendant
les rideaux noirs non parce que vous
êtes drôle parce est farceur parce que
vous êtes toujours disponible vous êtes
amicales oui ou c en était un groupe
formidable et marielle brûlé par les
verriers rochefort il est en était un
groupe de deux farceurs par l'ancré vers
un jour bon revenait de la cantine de
l'opéra parce que manger à la cantine
opéra j'étais au deuxième balcon du
conservatoire et il m'a dit t'es pas
chiche de plonger dans le rideau j'ai
plongé dans le rideau il amoindrit d'eau
est venu avec moi je suis tombé de là
haut avec le rideau et tout pouvait
faire faire n'importe quelle connerie
n'importe quelle conne vous était donc
ils étaient huit jours à pied wii est
d'accord et si vous voulez mais rapport
du ravec duck sauce y est donc toujours
en vie dans cette cantine de l'opéra un
jour avec marielle on avait un petit peu
poussé sur le beaujolais et il y avait
un clodo qui était là et il y avait une
fête du conservatoire et moi je prie de
clodo son litron dans la poche mal rasé
je les fais rentrer et avait directeur
qui était la d1000 peut pas rentrer et
j'ai dit c'est mon père
rentrée et je suis arrivé à du luxe et
là il ya des manques tu vas toi l'amour
en fuite depuis qu'est ce que c'est je
suis mon père et lendemain dicks
m'offrait un costume pour leurs repères
pour groupe at il assuré on ne sait pas
on perd ça n'a pas fait rire vous jouez
neale directeur d'ailleurs bon c'est
vrai que notamment chez drucker vous
avez souvent à raconter vos rapports
difficiles avec pierre dux mais je
m'aperçois quand même c'était pas sur le
professeur qui n'avait aucune confiance
en vous et je vois par exemple je vois
par rené simon qui était un des très
grands professeurs et un jour il dit
parlant de vous aider il dit avec une
gueule pareil comment voulez vous qu'il
fasse du théâtre il fait partie du
central où quoi on s'attend à recevoir
un direct du gauche dès qu'on s'approche
de lui et puis il est là encore là je
crois que je vais voilà il dit aussi
mais mon petit rail s'adresse à vous
mais mon petit tu n'es pas fait pour ce
métier je ne peux rien faire pour toi tu
ne feras carrière qu'à 50 ans en
attendant engage toi dans l'armée
devance l'appel c'est vrai ben oui parce
que finalement la plupart des
professeurs trouvez vous n'aviez aucun
avenir et aucun navire dont j'aie jamais
rencontré mon départ au ces pour revenir
à tout petit peu en arrière quand j'ai
dit à mon père je voulais faire des
théâtres il avait un grand ami qui était
andré bruno ce qu'ils étaient l'an
sociétaires et le créateur de cyrano à
la comédie française et à l'époque il
jouait le dossier avec pierre brasseur
au théâtre marigny et
il a dit à mon père un bain bon aloi
mois le petit et j'arrive dans la loge à
l'entracte il fait alors tu es le fils
de paul ajouté oui eh ben on va jouer
une scène jets n'ont jamais battus c'est
bien une fable alors je lui ai dit le
savetier le financier au bout de quatre
heures il s'est arrêté et m'a dit t'es
nul
frêche avait rien d'abord tapas de
physique tape à doite à rien donc ça
partait très mal vu dès le départ mais
mon père était formidable parce que
toujours il me disait mais moi aussi on
me casser des bus était il faut lutter
et après je me suis habitué parce que
toute ma vie on a toujours dit à non il
est pas bon il est pas ci fais pas ça
alors vous devez pas être votre physique
c'est vrai qu'avec votre physique votre
votre tête sympathique mais quand même
qu'à bosser parce que vous avez déjà le
nez cassé vous on peut dire pour
commander vous inventer un nouveau genre
de beauté parce que jusqu'à présent à ce
moment là il ya la beauté parfaite de
gérard philipe la beauté parfaite de
jean marc hé oui j'arrive autres pascal
ces gens là vous allez mettre à la mode
appelé les gueules simple le charme je
dirais plus que la beauté le chat est
aujourd'hui après il ya eu deux perdu
aujourd'hui à vincent perez et ça
continue et maintenant il ya une filière
que vous avez créés j'ai ouvert la porte
neuve et la mort c'est vrai oui mais
dans suis très content mais à l'époque
non c'est vrai que ce n'était pas
évident chez je jouais j'étais vous et
utilise en rigolant tout à l'heure mais
c'est vrai que tout est vrai pour jouer
le bon copain oui mais c'est vrai quand
on vous voit la jeune 17 18 ans quand
même les femmes craquent est là devant
nous enfin vous était révolté et c'est
pour ça que vous savez que je n'avais
pas de complexe à ce que me disaient ses
professeurs parce que par exemple dû
peser mort est due et son armée pouvait
très bien sur les terrains conseiller
mais est pas un médian vous pouvez pas
prendre une femme dans les bras on y
croira pas heureusement que j'en prenais
dans la vie sinon
il voulait absolument que je sous l'ailé
alors le sii badauds le fait que vous
n'ayez pas eu de
là vous exagérez ça serait fini comme ça
si je les écoutais
tête de coisy moto n'était pas mécontent
de mon physique vous dis franchement les
nommer monsieur est très pâle et
moelleux et mais on me le disait
beaucoup
on vous le disait chez les hommes qui
vous lisent émerger un ballet femmes oui
les parts égales d'amour mais quand même
ça c'est déjà vais pas plaindre mais les
hommes dans la profession beaucoup mais
le fait n'est pas eu de prix sorti du
conservatoire fait que vous n'êtes pas
entré à la comédie france oui et j'avais
envie de rentrer à l'examiner en massage
pour mes camarades aussi la nécessité
tout à l'heure notre rêve c'était de
rentrer à la comédie française ne
pensais pas du tout aussi des masques à
l'époque c'était la grande comédie
française je peux dire qu'elle veut
maintenant rires mais vous saviez
clarion de but coup
hirsch en pas tout ces gens qu'on
m'admire et donc le rêve c'était de
pouvoir entrer dans dans cette boue oui
mais vous avez quand même un peu joué à
la comédie française j'ai un peu joué à
l'époque ça s'appelait stagiaires oui
elle vous avez joué dans fantasio de
musset et l'annoncé faite à marie de
paul claudel folk et j'ai connu paul
claudel pas chez cauet il me parlait pas
mais il est il était assis dans la salle
avec une énorme couverture est juste de
temps en temps quand on parle et on
entendait crier c'est pas beau
et et avec marielle moi je vais là j'ai
encore ma réplique je devais dire mon
pain et eau gelée mon pain et où je leur
île et le soir de la générale j'ai fait
mon palais tout fleuret alors bon ça a
fait rire dans la salle ce qui n'est pas
le but de claudel leur m'a appelé m'a
dit faut pas faire ça et dans fantasio
j'ai fait pire parce que dans fantasia
je joue il croque mort et j'arrivais et
le jeune premier de même vivre fantasio
disait aulaqi en tirez vous et j'ai tiré
nous enterrons saint-jean sa place est
vacante vous pouvez la prendre c'est
beaucoup et je dis ça comme ça belles
phrases metteur en scène m'a dit j'ai
des acteurs jeune homme je dis oui alors
vous dites nous enterrons saint-jean sa
place est vacante vous pouvez la prendre
éreintant imbécile et vous dit si vous
voulez la générale a ri
le pauvre fantasio se ramassait une
soirée pouvant table tout le monde bat
images rentrent au noir avec un espèce
de chapeau de bouère des derniers qui
portaient le cercueil et lee nous
enterrons saint jean vous pouvait la
prendre je disparais et ne soit pas
juste la tête je fais si vous voulez
triomphe prions en triomphe et là je
suis appelé par l'administrateur garder
caf qui vous êtes un malade
je suis humaine on m'a demandé de promat
en larmes a fui à pied je n'ai plus
jamais rejouer
c'est ma prestation la comédie française
s'est arrêtée là mais quoi vous étiez un
provocateur
c'est incroyable j'ai envie de faire
l'idiot oui alors c'est ballot loue un
peu plus tard on vous a proposé de jouer
scapin la comédie française et vous avez
refusé parce que vous étiez en cinéma
oui j'ai des nantis léman ont proposé à
l'époque des faits que je rentre un an
ça me semblait très long très long la
gerbille et puis c'était un peu c'était
un peu tard leur vie vous avez su vous
avez souvent été disons un acteur
comique un acteur comique irie j'ai
débuté pour une course à l'acteur
comique souvent il résiste notamment
dans les films de de broca de et de
gérard oury voici une scène du
magnifique de philippe de broca qui se
termine par une question que me posent
jacques team bissell mais voyez
jacqueline bisset je trouve cette
question vraiment elle est très
pertinente
les bombes enfin tout le monde vous
croyez mort ou peu de la coalition
comptent fou arigato andorre avec à
pékin il pas one
vous avez de la fièvre 38 2 et c'est pas
toi
et qu'est ce que c'est barry temps
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire faut que ça
mûrisse
et leurs études à 9 heures pour y aller
où ça
trophée dans l'eau chaude
la vraie dit toutes les demi heures mais
enfin karpov l'albanie il a fusé les
chinois j'avance pas accompagné c'est
mal aux doigts compagnie
[Musique]
quand vous allez arrêter de faire le con
la très bonne question quand est ce que
vous allez arrêter de faire le con et
finalement on s'abaisse vous n'avez
jamais arrêté j'avais d'après ledit
arrêté non mais d'après le livre il n'ya
pas un tournage inquiet vous n'ayez fait
des canulars des farces et attrapes et
des choses invraisemblables au risque de
vous faire jeter dehors par le par
l'hôtelier ma mère faisait le pari de se
faire rejeter par l'hôtel hier hong kong
oui parce que c'était un italien et avec
gilles de la mar 2nd cascadeur qui bat
qui va tout appris et on avait fait le
pari tous les deux de se faire jeter
hors de l'hôtel est alors de broca aussi
voulait faire comme nous et on lui a
fait une blague a de moins qu'un
terrible il était en train de manger
avec les murs sur bresle et de broc 1 le
producteur tout le monde et le directeur
italien qu'on avait mis dans votre poche
après lui avoir fait les pires choses on
lui dit vous allez allez dire que
monsieur belmondo mais c'est al ahmar
sont tout nus dans la boîte et c'est un
scandale dont l'amour génie tarifs et
une scandale belmondo de braga s'est
tenue dans la boîte l'autre puis se
déshabille pas paul dans la boîte
évidemment il était bon
mais j'aime beaucoup une blague une
blague que vous avez fait fait à
françois périer pendant le tournage de
stavisky d'alain resnais
donc là je crois que vous rentrez un peu
un peu saoul avec votre frère louis
frère mon ami heures charlie cook
besseyre françois périer et avec son
épouse dans une chambre oui il est dans
une chambre et
on a pris une énorme de la sarre mois
avec une glace une armoire vous avez
monté oui à monter on a mis devant sa
porte c'est ça la coller à la porte
coller à la peau la glacerie vers 2h30
du matin on a frappé à la porte très
fort et il a ouvert la porte et sa femme
jada il s'est vu dans ces villes ça va
mieux a dit qu'est ce que c'est et a dit
c'est rien c'est moi
l'admirable mirabeau rubrique
questions un peu plus sérieuse moi je
vois très bien vous aimez vous amuser
vous aimez faire le con pardon
expression mais est-ce qu'il ya pas ça
derrière une volonté chez vous comment
dirais-je une volonté de désordre une
volonté de toucher à l'absurde je sais
pas vous savez je suis né comme ça à moi
tout petit j'avais trouvé 2
de faire l'imbécile j'étais enfant de
coeur serait déjà l'idiot avec les
burettes donc ça a commencé très tôt
c'est un peu dans ma tête comme on m'a
reproché de faire des cascades des trucs
comme ça moi je faisais par goussé quand
j'étais jeune chez ma mère je me rendais
au balcon du cinquième étage pour faire
peur aux voisins ça mais ça m'amuse et
voyez si je trouvais ça drôle c'est vrai
mais j'ai intégré un petit peu il vient
et s'ils voulaient on m'a reproché toute
ma vie s'est ouvert au conservatoire
c'est ses 110 est un clown c'est pas un
acteur oui mais même par exemple alain
resnais qui sait peut-être vous fassiez
l'imbécile un rennais a beaucoup
d'humour il aime bien ça perturbe quand
même le tournage d'un film là non parce
que je ne la gênait pas dans son rôle si
si tous les témoignages là sont
concordants pendant leur antre les
scènes vous faites aussi l'imbécile est
ce qui fait que alors que les autres
sont là en train de
déstabiliser compagnie mais quand ils
sont comme ça me déstabilise aussi
vrai ça qu'on va perpétuer l y en a qui
ont besoin d'être comme ça ma conjointe
type qui avant qui va jouer un rôle
dramatique et quand je vois comme ça
moi ça me donne envie de rire c'est
d'ailleurs je peux vous raconter une
histoire en vidéo ugg belgique quand
j'ai joué léon morin prêtre jacques
terray un peu mon ami melville parce
qu'il voulait toujours je veux que je me
concentre et un jour m'a demandé de me
concentrer je me suis endormi dans ma
loge mais il fut autrefois il y avait
cette actrice charbon et emmanuelle riva
qui jouait avec moi et elle voulait
donner le moteur pour que son émotion
arrive au bon moment évidemment ça me
faisait rire et
un camarade schwarz qui était caméramens
mais je voyais déjà kirié et là
j'attendais derrière et tout d'un coup
les langues sont venus à la fée moteur
quand je suis rentré j'étais cool
évident menneville ça n'a pas beaucoup
mes joueurs françoise fabian pendant que
vous tourniez le voleur et le 10 10 elle
parle elle dit moi j'ai plutôt besoin de
concentration alors que lui la
concentration salle angoisse jusqu'au
dernier moment il fait des blagues il
rigole il va il vient il fait du bruit
quand on dit moteur il est à l'aise
parce qu'il s'est déchargé de tout ça
peut décontenancer certains acteurs qui
ont besoin du contraire baissé mais
quand même des rares exemples quand même
au cinéma de type qui fait qui fait le
con avant avant la réplique qui ne se
concentre pas en soi qui apprendra aussi
oui enfin bon 2 2 c'est quand même pas
beaucoup elle soit l'ensemble du cinéma
français américains et norvégiens
l'avoir je connais pas beaucoup alors
les
les acteurs que vous admirez le plus ce
sont quand même des comics oui bon gars
mais vous savez bien sûr mais bon je
vous admire beaucoup trop s'y met non
mais également le plus oui quand j'étais
jeune et moi allez voir ferland belle
c'était une chose bon fernandel
aujourd'hui on n'en parle plus tellement
c'était un immense secteur et qu'il y
avait un comique en lui lançant des je
vous devine sg
fernandez gels et très peu connu mais
j'ai une petite anecdote charmante avait
clairement belle et je tournais sur un
plateau à côté de lui quand je suis
devenu connu j'ai voulu absolument
connaître fernandez c'était vraiment une
chose que j'aime beaucoup et je l' ai vu
m'a fait
j'adore je vais vous donner un conseil à
masser hamas et amassé
alors été son conseil alors ça tombait
mal parce que vous avez vous avez claqué
vraiment le tout vos cachets dans les
jours dans l'espace urbain ce groupe
est formidable c'est devenu producteur
ce qui était un métier quand même à
risque il avait acheté un théâtre une
réponse pas vous rapporte beaucoup
d'argent alors c'est pas vrai c'est ça
non même s'il y avait eu le berry avait
michel simon les bourbes il un bourvil
avec qui j'ai la chance de tours mais
vous savez que vous savez imiter bourvil
non c'est pas imiter et et puis c'est
quand même tout est celui qui nous a mis
un peu plus et michel simon michel simon
oui parce que je crois que michel simon
ça dépasse l'acteur
s'il joue plus la comédie
c'est quand on le regarde j'ai eu la
chance de le voir au théâtre dans une
reprise de fric frac puis après j'ai vu
dans les branches de sassafras est
vraiment à chaque fois je suis sorti les
bras ballon et je me disais je sais pas
si je dois continuer à être acteur
arriver à ça ça c'est une chose mais
vous êtes allé lui parler oui j'ai été
lui parler il avait connu mon père et
quand j'ai été le voir dans sa loge ça
c'était quand il a joué fripes alger
pause les allées le voir c'était un
jeune acteur avoir 17 ans donc je
pensais aller le voir mais dans les
branches de cette approche était déjà
connu dix ans et j'ai été le voir et il
m'a regardé ma vie vous n'êtes pas ses
idées politiques
et j'ai trouvé ça charmant
les blacks ont fait quelque chose détail
intéressant c'est qu'il aurait voulu
jouer hamlet wii et qui évidemment lui a
jamais prier c'est justement la verdure
comme ça une interview et cette chose
formidable on lui disait mais vous avez
fait la plus belle carrière et tout
ladino je ne sais pas c'est pas fait ce
que je voulais j'aurais voulu jouer à
mener et pourquoi pas
alors autre grand acteur mais qui vous
avez tourné c'est jean gabin lino
ventura l'on va vous voir des extraits
de deux films signés tous les deux
d'henri verneuil successivement un singe
en hiver et 100 mille dollars au soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors quoi qu'est ce qu'il est ce qui se
passe si ce n'est pas une autre personne
le jour des morts c'est mon chauffeur
n'avait pas freiné on l'écrasé il a
freiné et ben alors c'est fini n'en
parlons plus c'est trop commode on est
venus en pèlerinage ou me sont les
parents jamais allégée à votre
pèlerinage de la route et qui valait
bien la peine où travaillent au khyber
swat mais pourquoi tu avais pensé je
prend la défense de personnes voyaient
papier pas dans son état normal
c'est fou quand même ce qu'un mec peut
changer vous
le rappelle toi rocco à tampico à murcie
à caracas eh ben on partageait tout jeu
les risques le pognon les filles et là
tu t'es tiré au petit matin en faux
jetons sans rien à dire
entre nous tu crois que c'est bien dit 1
on peut pas dire que tu es tout à fait
tort
mais torres emploi raison que j'aurai
encore plus raison de toi
c'est moi qui tient la carabine
et puis confidences pour confidences des
comptes sont un peu truqués pendant
quinze ans qu'est-ce qu'on a partagé des
routes pourri de la poussière et des
coups durs jamais rien d'autre dans la
vie on partage toujours la merde jamais
le pognon personnes
avec lequel des deux bus avez vous eu le
plus de complicité ont haussé avec les
deux sincèrement parce que
gabin en tournée le singe en hiver
c'était à deauville à l'époque et pas
beaucoup de monde c'était en janvier il
y avait personne et à une grande
complicité il y avait cet acteur
roquevaire qui faisait rire énormément
gens il y avait toujours des histoires
de fous et puis moi je à l'époque
j'avais des voitures sport et gabin
voulait pas que je prenne la voiture
sport ce qu'il faudrait ça dangereux
alors j'allais avec lui souvent dans sa
voiture est alors vraiment avec ma
voiture j'aurais mis ça en faire le fou
20 minutes et je mettais une heure pour
aller au tournage parce qu'elle est
toujours surfer fall et le ralentir et
un jour on est rentré un peu sous la
neige alors il a fait passer la
troisième puis d'un coup il a fait un
petit coup de secondes et pourrait
rentrer en seconde alors il avait cette
ressource formidable c'est que tous les
matins quand ils arrivent ils avaient la
casquette enfoncée jusqu'à la jsa vagin
non g bâle au bio là ce soir jambon
salade
et le soir arrive et on allait dîner il
y a elle perd quand même un petit whisky
et hommes c'est reparti
mais le lendemain matin ça recommence et
le violet avec ventura vis-à-vis la
complicité du sportif
on allait au football en sang
ont joué au football en six ans ce qui
n'est pas alors à propos de football à
une chose qui me stupéfient c'est que
vous ayez été gardien de but gardiens de
but c'est celui qui défend moi je vais
je voyais en attaquant en avant semble
celui qui fonce pour celui qui lui qui
prend les coups mais je ne prenais pas
de causes mêmes envolées et c'est ce à
quoi j'étais un oiseau mois dans la
4c si
ben oui mais j'avais ça oui non si vous
aviez parce qu'à l'époque vous savez il
y avait connu on et vignal c'était ça
faisait rêver tout le monde est donc au
mas et ses spectaculaires où ça il ya
deux que les gens aient des enfants
retiennent beaucoup c'est l'avant-centre
et le gardien de but bon gardien de but
est moins mis en valeur aujourd'hui
quoique barthez la la coupe du monde a
fait un malheur dont il a redonné ses
lettres de noblesse au gardien de but
parce que souvent à la télé ils ont
tendance à montrer de gars quatre pattes
karma cela ballon
s'envole avez raison le futur cascadeur
il ne pouvait pas être avancée mais ne
pouvait très bien que la ddc lascoux tf1
alors on va pas parler comme de vos
cascades parce que j'en ai assez qu'on
va pas montré ont doublé sur voila voila
une aussi catherine barma
toujours admiré chez vous et sécurité au
conservatoire il n'y en ait pas eu que
les veaux profession n'est pas vu
toujours pensé que vous aviez quelque
chose d'assez rare chez les commerces et
l'art de vous déplacer c'est quelque
chose vous ne trouvez pas que c'est
assez rare savoir remplacer c'est ce que
vous dites là mon professeur georges
leroy recall et la classe d'ensemble
acquis par contre on est très bien que
tu es un grand sociétaires d'accueillir
française qui était un petit peu
illuminée souvent il avait dit un jour à
roche ont gardé le marché cet animal
était frappé par la manière dont je me
déplacer c'est le seul qui vous l'avez
dit alors vous votre palmarès beaucoup
évidemment de réalisateurs et dans tous
les genres alors il ya verneuil de broca
j'ai cité miyako de chabrol et marc
allégret claude claude sautet vittorio
de sica mais jean pierre melville et
jean becker jacques deray louis malle
gérard oury françois truffaut claude
lelouch alain resnais philippe labro
jean paul rappeneau georges lautner
patrice leconte fait bref c'est vraiment
vraiment
j'oubliais je vais je vanille primes et
enfin celui auquel votre nom restera
attaché ou celui dont le nom restera
toujours attachés aux vôtres c'est
évidemment là jean luc godard alors et
vous avez fait donc le petit court
métrage on a eu trois autres longs
métrages on va voir un extrait de 2
verra pas une femme et d'une femme on
verra d'abord à bout de souffle et puis
pierrot le fou
mais violent cet emprunt
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites ici et que des
tests faits j'ai pas dis que je
détestais j'ai dit que j'avais beaucoup
d'ennemis alors vous êtes en danger
riche en danger tu veux pas venir à rome
avec ma pâtissier fait quoi là bas on
verra non j'ai beaucoup de chance a fait
après initial maintenant qu'est ce que
tu fais sûrement tout y descend les
champs qu'est ce que c'est les champs et
champs elysées
moi il faut que j'aille avenue georges
cinq ans qui laissent à leur monte avec
moi j'ai ce cas là vous alors
10h48 dionne
tellement fière fois d'horoscope
qu'est-ce que celles de lowe's cos
l'horoscope c'est l'avenir j'ai envie de
savoir l'avenir patoine
25 75 02
scolaire griffon et dames
qui sait
et le dit
ils en feront vient
d'annoncer la part de personnes
[Musique]
à
je voulais dire
pourquoi
voilà et c'est cette photo enfin passage
vous vous êtes maquillée de bleu qui
illustre un ouvrage qui vient de sortir
que vous connaissez pas je qui est
signée jean douchet s'appelle tout
simplement nouvelle vague sont tous les
documents qui racontent la nouvelle
vague les deux photographique bien
entendu mais aussi les textes et
notamment il ya beaucoup de cétacés
désopilante de lire les critiques
notamment sur par exemple à bout de
souffle basse n'était pas unanime
à nantes où l'on croit toujours que à
bout de souffle a été encensé et pas du
tout cet été et moi de vous l'offrir
grilles anti merci et alors et c'était
attaquer beaucoup et moi même je me
faisais attaqué aussi donc c'est avec le
temps que les gens trouvaient ça très
très bien quand vous avez détourné bout
de souffle est ce que vous aviez
conscience de tourner un film qu'elle
est très important dans les mêmes est
très triste orange est tout à fait
honnête avec vous mais pas du tout je
m'amusais beaucoup parce que dans ces
cas vous amusez
vous auriez rigoler aussi parce que
quand même on tournait n'y avait pas de
son il y avait là une caméra matchs ont
été serrés ya encore des petites
voitures déposent poussé caméras étaient
planqués là dedans l'ajustement les
rôles tribunes on descendait sur les
champs-elysées comme ça et je pensais
que ce film ne sortirait pas alors
j'étais d'autant plus décontractée
sincèrement non pas que je prenais
godard pour un imbécile ou un type qui
n'avait pas de talent mais moi le petit
cinéma que j'avais fait il y avait du
son et y avait des sages et la scripte
il avait foutu à la porte y avait pas de
script il n'y a pas pas de santé - il
n'y avait rien je me disais ce film là
ne ne sortira pas la nouvelle vague on
en parle encore bien entendu c'est
antoine de bec qui vient de publier la
nouvelle vague portrait d'une dune jeu
des c'est donc un essai là aussi avec
des photos et il dit ceci parce que
quand même c'est un succès considérable
fonctions et où ça va vous l'aï beaucoup
mais il dit le cinéma tendait un miroir
à la société il était déformant mais
cela n'avait rien d'exceptionnel ce
qu'il a été ces la force avec laquelle
une génération a voulu s'y voir souvent
s'y reconnaître parfois s'y opposer et
je crois qu'il a vraiment raison c'était
pas unanime y avait aussi des gens qui
n'annonçait ne sait plus bien chez
flammarion il ya des gens qui étaient
choqués par le film qui était un peu
ardu et vous avez montré pierrot le fou
aussi mais pierrot le fou a déclenché
aussi d une sorte de large
chez les gens voulaient beaucoup après
on m'a dit pourquoi vous ne tournez pas
avec godard mais à l'époque on disait
pourquoi vous tournez rigolade c'est
vrai ce que je devais payer rôle vous
beaucoup de producteurs de cinéma 17 fou
pour pouvoir retourner avec ce type
c'était une stratégie de votre part de
mêlée alternativement le cinéma
populaire disons le cinéma d'art et
d'essai c'est à dire godard verneuil uri
et b rennais melville et de broc à bien
ces mêmes c'est une stratégie c'est le
hasard nous c'était la chance aussi vous
savez c'est la chance qui a eu tous ces
gens là à cette même époque aussi ça
c'était quand même un important ils
étaient tous dans des gens variés il
aurait pu avoir que des melville ou
codées de brocart mais vous pouviez
faire le couillon avec de broca et d'un
coup devenir très très sérieux avec mail
donc si vous voulez quand j'avais fait
une comédie j'avais brusquement envie de
faire un film policier
donc j'avais melilla verneuil donc je il
y avait toute une variété
c'était un peu la palette est elle à
jamais la chance aussi que ces gens
avaient envie de tourner avec moi parce
que bon moi j'ai jamais pris mon
téléphone pour appeler quelqu'un jamais
non jamais jamais je ne pourrai pas le
faire non pas bon mais je trouve que
j'ai refait pas par fierté je trouve que
si quelqu'un veut tourner avec vous
c'est parce qu'il a il a envie de te
faire voir aussi envie de
dire non et oui je veux pas la db6 et je
trouve qu'un acteur faut avoir envie de
travailler avec lui mais pourquoi dalton
en est une part envie de tourner avec un
mets toi
ça les aiderait de dire à un type géant
victor est avec vous et c'est pareil
pour ben oui bon pour quoi faire à vous
veniez de ses parents que vous ne faites
pas d'orgueil parce que j'ai joué au
foot mais non mais je trouve je trouve
que le rôle du metteur en scène c'est à
dire ou de l'écrivain il écrit une pièce
où il écrit un film ici il se dit ah là
dedans je vois bernard pivot il appelle
bernard pivot c'est oui ça m'est arrivé
là c'est ça la balle le vrai truc c'est
pas des sépales acteurs qui doit
déclencher sur tes veines et des
garanties vous
écouter vous allez toutes les choses qui
me sont arrivées ce sont des gens qui
m'ont appelé en me disant non pas parce
que j'étais que je me prends jean paul
belmondo et tout au tout le monde va
m'appeler c'est mon jeu il faut parce
que mon jeu leur plaît qu'ils ont envie
de l'espace que vous aussi si ces maps
les bombes d'hier il faut faire tout à
fait autre chose ne faites pas ça parce
que les fonctions vous dit un qualifié
du belmondo ben oui il voulait que ça du
moins de finesse c'est ce que je fais le
mieux encore
on vous a vu évidemment souvent dans des
rôles vos rôles cd rôle de l'aventurier
de gangsters de filou de deux flics
aussi de deux conteneurs dirait être
aussi de prête à voir et en lainage et
bien justement là vous avez
mauvais leclerc de soldats mais vous
avez aussi joué des rôles ce qu'on peut
appeler des contre-emploi indé contre
emploi et or précisément on va vous voir
à mon avis mais vous dira pas le
contraire me semble dans 2 contre emploi
s'est déroulée jouer un rôle de prêtre
dans les roues dans léon morin prêtre de
melville et puis un amoureux de berne et
qui ne correspond pas dans la scène dans
la sirène du mississipi de truffaut avec
catherine deneuve
mes frères
est-ce le froid qui vous engourdi
j'espère que le beau soleil va voir
animer un peu
vain qui dévie d'or chapelet pendant la
sainte messe c'est pourtant pas le
moment
là qu'ils vont faire leur petit
d'émotion près d'une statue alors que le
très saint sacrement et là parmi vous
qui vous attend présent est vivant
et puis tout le monde pas avant le
dernier évangile
est dont 6 brésil qui était votre dieu
maintien du dimanche
et frère de soyons enfin comme c'est ici
qui se pressent autour de notre seigneur
manqué l'étouffer et empêcher les gens
de voir et même de l'approché
si vous n'êtes que des chrétiens non
vous éloigner les hésitants leur hôtel
envie de venir
alors que chacun de vous doit être
apôtres dans son milieu
je voulais vous dire aussi chantons
notre messe paroissiale avec un peu plus
de virilité s'entraîner sur les finales
au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit ainsi souhaité y
allons un peu de temps souvient
aussi
ça c'est ce que tu fais dans la rue
commerçant en donne mal au travail
celui du bonheur voilà c'est ça
formidable
quand c'est rouge le plus mal aux yeux
je veux plus te regarde
dans
les yeux fermés pourtant je te vois
je vérifie
si tu avais tu passerais mon temps à
caresser ton visage ton
corps c'est
si j'étais sourds
j'apprendrai à lire sur les lèvres avec
mes doigts comme ça
même si tout ça doit finir mal
chercheurs des domaines
oui alors donc ces deux films d'ailleurs
qu'ils n'ont pas très bien marché parce
que public et non pas du tout par été
surprise peut-être vous a t'il mieux
accepté d'ailleurs en prêtre en fait
très jeune prêtre oui très très jeune et
j'ai un début j'ai l'impression de voir
excusez-moi d'edouard fernandel dans ton
camillo
bon j'exagère et mai et herman revanche
le public vous encore moins reçu dans le
film de truffaut parce que là vous étiez
vraiment un contre en poche c'est le
l'amoureux transi peu éthique et berné
c'est oui vous savez à l'époque que
j'allais y avait encore de la boxe à
paris et j'allais au palais des sports
et je me faisais insulter après ce film
parce qu'un succombé oui insultes et
enfin pas les gens ne frappait pas mes
gens me disaient mais comment comment
vous vous laissez faire je me suis dit à
la fin il va l'étrangler et non le biais
pas ce qu'il s'attendait un peu et
beaucoup de misère catherine on se
révolte voilà une révolte qui
s'attendaient à ce que mon personnage
pour eux ils devaient céder qui
considère que dans la vie vous ne jamais
vous n'auriez acceptera jamais l'image
des voix lasse jamais de
voir que finalement il ya souvent une
adéquation pour le public entre là parce
que le public se fait une idée de goût
finalement deux fils et de l'acteur qui
l'aiment ou des acteurs qui vous aime et
il ya des choses finalement ils veulent
pas les voir mais c'est intéressant d'y
aller quand même parce que pour l'acteur
c'est amusant à jouer et puis bon
alors un contre emploi lors ce qui est
tout à fait curieux c'est quand vous
avez tourné dans le stabilise qui
d'alain resnais là au fond où on a
reproché à alain resnais plutôt de vous
avoir donné le rôle tout ça ce qui est
assez drôle faisait danser états belge
et produit le film entièrement au plus
il était producteur entièrement du film
et rennais n'avait pas tourné je crois
depuis cinq ans et pour ne pas gêner
raid et je ne lui avait pas dit que
j'étais producteur je vais producteurs
mais les gays qui était mon frère et de
ce qu'ils ne savaient pas que c'était
moi le est en marche on lui a reproché à
près de m'avoir pris soit disant aussi
que j'avais les directives ou je ne sais
quoi bon cv mais est ce que les
journalistes et les critiques vous
paraissent parfois de mauvaise foi
soit honnête souvent mais je crois - oui
mais non mais je crois que vous savez le
jour où il n'était pas de mauvaise foi
avec moi aussi me trouvais tout le temps
si je disais tout temps belmondo est
extraordinaire belmondo ici je serais
très très inquiet d'ailleurs le jour où
je dirais un truc où je suis vraiment
formidable et une à deux partout je veux
dire il est temps de sortir et ça va mal
c'est c'est un peu normal c'est sur
toute une carrière je crois que vous
savez il faut faire la part des choses
aussi je ne leur en veux pas du tout
moment vous en vouliez à la main à temps
quand ils ont fait une cabale contre moi
c'est différent vous m'attaquez de bien
méchant mais mais si vous attaquez pas
mais il avait fait une cabale contre
l'as des as qui n'était pas honnête
c'est différent ils ont été malhonnête
dont je leur ai
répondu jusqu'à leur répondre non mais
ce que je veux dire sinon bon si vous
jouez à l'inter au théâtre de la
huchette et que vous êtes un acteur qui
a pas beaucoup de succès ils vont me
dire du bien de vous ça je comprends
très bien mais quand vous avez quelqu'un
qui a du succès qui est censé avoir de
l'argent qui est censé avoir des belles
femmes mais et vous vous êtes en train
d'éclore petits papiers pour qu'elle
vous envie de dire qu'il est bien puis
ça je les comprends ils en on veut pas
parce qu'en plus ils vont pas rentrer
chez elle enfin vous diront plus il fait
des pompes à cet acteur je pense qu'ils
aient un peu tout ça vous pensez
ouvriers jeunesse comme ça pas les
journalistes et critiques enfin quand
même on aurait coûté voyez vous êtes et
vous
imaginez une envie aussi aussi grâce aux
écoutes et sincèrement à part les autos
sinon un critique c'est pas moi qui ai
by guitry disait c'est par métier il n'y
a jamais un petit enfant comme il a dit
quand vous demandez un enfant essaie de
le faire il ya pas que des critiques ont
parlé de godard de truffes oms était
décrété ils sont devenus des grands
maîtres 26 vous rester critique tout
votre vie c'est effrayant écoutez vous
rendez compte aller tous les soirs tous
les jours sans exception terrain par des
types des pièces déjà vu cent fois
tension amené ma jeu c'est effrayant
faut pas leur en vouloir mais surtout
pas après ce que vous n'êtes dire là mon
avis ça ça va être un spectacle
en devenant le très populaire bébel et
vous êtes toujours dans le classement du
journal du dimanche toujours dans les
trois ou quatre premiers donc parmi les
français préféré le des français est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas couper du belmondo
kemmel intelligentsias quai mais
l'ajustement de la critique qu'il est
qui vous aimez dans god arrivée dans
peter brook qui vous aiment qu'ils
aimaient qui est mais comment dire
l'acteur anti conventionnel est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas devenu avec bébel un
acteur conventionnel d'abord c'est pas
moi qui me suis nommé bbc tromper parce
que nous l'aimons surnom à l'époque
c'était pepel à cause des bas fonds je
veux dire parce que j'avais dur le même
col roulé et hubert des chambres d'amis
l'hibernation bâle est surnommé pépé
mais je me suis jamais coupé de
personnes c'est eux qui vous coupent
parce que tout d'un coup vont clairement
prête ça ne marche pas vous trouve
génial la sirène du mississipi ça marche
pas on veut trop génial avec le temps
bon si vous faites
un film qui fait un million d'entrées il
ne vous aime pas ça annonce sur jeunes
et la non la saison villas ont dit non
mais si oui vous comprenez pas s'exercer
et je trouve ça normal je vais vous dire
moi c'est que l'âme de l'homme est aussi
noir mais s'épanouit à petit maintenant
parce que c'est pas grave le cinéma de
toute façon n'est pas une chose aussi
importante et aussi là un acteur si
jamais suicidé sur une mauvaise critique
de toute façon donc c'est pas c'est pas
grave ce qu'ils vont dire ils vont pas
vous casser la carrière si vous cassez à
carrière je dirais c'est grave ils vont
pas le faire c'est pas ça je veux dire
et je m'exprime peut-être mal mais parce
que je joue pas dans cette
petite chose que je sais c'est pas
nouveau ça quand même le succès je suis
pas le premier oui je suis pas une
victime
c'est bien une victime se porte très
bien et avant moi et pagnol il a et b
vous avez du citrix sur la critique donc
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et molière et
les ap donc ça c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
et puis c'est pas d'la et puis ça
existera toujours n'enlèvera pas les
critiquer je demande pas ce qu'on enlève
les crédits que ça fait ça fait partie
du métier ça fait partie des choses
quand on est jeune c'est vrai qu'on les
lit et qu'on regarde et on dit à son
papa et sa maman t'as vu c'est une bonne
critique mais à mon âge je vais appeler
partager le bonheur dans la pièce que
vous je veux faire part unie dont
frédéric ouvert du crif d'eric emmanuel
schmitt les critiques en prennent un
sérieux coup aussi au passage mais je
n'offrirai cavaillès meetic dit des
choses très très juste d'ailleurs ils
n'ont pas su voir que c'est un écrivain
formidable qu'il a écrit une pièce
formidable sur le sur le terrain alors
tant pis pour intervenir aux autos
théâtre donc en 1987 vous revenez au
théâtre et vous jouez de jouer qu'idc
d'ailleurs robert hossein qui vous a mis
en scène qui a eu et qui a été le
premier à vous faire revenir sur scène
c'était par fatigue du cinéma que vous
avez vous êtes remonté sur gvt c'est
pendant des années j'ai annoncé mon
retour au théâtre ça devenait un galles
parce qu'à chaque interview c'est
terminé et quand est ce que votre
l'année prochaine
et un jour les projections du du
professionnel il y avait robert hossein
qui jouait dans le film et qui était là
et il y avait mon père à la projection
et
il a vu le film abyss est très très bien
aubert - et il m'a dit mais enfin mon
petit quand est ce que tu vas vraiment
faire ton métier
j'ai dit comme en fermant les cubains
oui le théâtre et mao scène à sauter là
dessus et moi je me suis dit
effectivement j'arrive quand même à un
âge où il était temps de revenir et 28
on dirait pas joué et je me suis dit je
rende pas maintenant je vais rentrer
pour dans un fauteuil roulant donc je
suis rentré dans kin j'ai repris l'amour
du théâtre des plans et
d'ailleurs le rôle de votre balade de
brasseurs de vie embrasser qui j'ai eu
la chance de la mégère apprivoisée
je peux dire ouais extraits et de keane
je suis pas gagner sa vie toujours menti
on a menti
soit il ce qu'on ne peut pas être et
parce qu'on en a assez d'être ce qu'on
est on joue pour pas se connaître et
parce qu'on se connaît trop
joué les héros parce qu'on est là depuis
cinq ans on est méchant
les assassins parce qu'on rêve depuis
son prochain bonjour rang jouve parce
qu'on aime la vérité
parce qu'on la déteste on joue parce
qu'on est menteur de décembre
11 bon joue parce qu'on ne tiendrait pas
parce que je sais pas d'où les chiens à
un moment où je cherche de jouer
alors je n'oublie pas vous avez joué
feydeau mais quand même keane cyrano de
bergerac
et puis aujourd'hui frédéric lemaître
dans la pièce de chemise ce sont tous
des personnages ébouriffant énorme des
grandes gueules des avec des destins
hors du commun est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas condamné à jouer ses personnages
vraiment tout à fait excessif c'est une
bonne condamnation oui non mais quand
condamné avec plaisir regardez au brésil
cuisinant mais vous savez à
erick laumet ce qui est très bien parce
que rien n'avait été écrit par au
théâtre pas vraiment pas de grandes
pièces cet acteur qui a marqué tout le
19e siècle c'était dommage qu'ils aient
rien sur lui et en même temps il a il a
montré le théâtre comme on l'a rarement
montrées au
théâtre donc être d'agît jean king oui
dans kin mais bon c'était en angleterre
nous ont montré ce qui se passait en
france et ce qui est beau de dans ses
personnages c'est moi le théâtre que
j'aime si c'est pour ces des personnages
excessive
les mesures voilà mais ce qui est bien
aussi dans la pièce de schmitz et qu' il
ya l'émotion en même temps et par
moments d'un coup un pays devient humain
tout son côté ralala sauvain et donc ces
deux parties à jouer pour un acteur
c'est déroule sublime oui mais qui parce
qu'ils sont un peu dans la démesure
voilà mes goûts série
moi j'avoue calais au théâtre pour jouer
juste dans mes boîtes et parler comme on
enfin de parler tous les deux là
j'aurais peur de m'ennuyer le soir via
le cinéma pour ça mais j'aime bien que
ça bouge voilà que ce soit fini groupe
et que ce soit physique et une troupe
retour et bien alors écoutez je crois
qu'on a fait on a fait je crois une
sorte de portrait de vous je pense que
téléspectateurs ont vu au fond il vous
connaît certains connaissent bien
d'autres moins bien on veut on fait un
portrait de vous à travers à travers ce
que vous propose à travers les extraits
qu'on a vu à travers enfin tout c'est
qu'on vit dans ses confidences tous ces
souvenirs que vous avez évoquées mais on
va simplement juste et vous répondez au
questionnaire dans quelques minutes
vous avez été plus fidèle en amitié
quand l'amour les banques c'est vrai je
dois le confesser
et alors là effectivement vous les avez
cité au début pierre vernier et jean
pierre marielle jean rochefort claude
rich michel beaune jean pierre bernard
et vous avez été d'une fidélité
extraordinaire c'est vraiment ils
étaient vos copains aux abattoirs et ils
sont restés vos amis oui avec claude
rich travers et vous savez on a eu la
chance de se connaît tous très jeunes 18
ans et aucun ne pensait être un jour
disons des vedettes est bon et tout le
monde a réussi là et on ne sait jamais
quitté et donc c'est ce que c'est un peu
comme mon père qui avait ses amis des
beaux-arts et les a8 toute sa vie il et
les amis de qu'on se fait à 18 ans non
mais c'est plus je trouve ça très beau
c'est la mobilité dans l'amitié autre
chose une particularité aussi c'est que
vous avez un score encore splendide mais
vous êtes un des rares acteurs ne vous
êtes jamais avoué s'être montre jamais
montrée nue à l'écran j'aime l'art est
pourquoi
je pense non non je pense pourquoi ce
mot crédit
je n'ai pas fait ce métier pour montrer
à poil ça vraiment pas mais vous dites
je me suis jamais montrée nue sasson
vous étonnez pas ce commerçant
aujourd'hui pratiquement tous les
voisins directs moi je vais vous dire je
me suis mis en caleçon mais par contre
ça fait un masque en ligne hulu ah oui
elles sont à pois alors ça on en a parlé
de ce qu'elles sont un poids alors si
j'ai été baladé l'asic est à l'air au
dessus de venise on aurait trouvé ça
très bien je suis trouvé que c'était
mieux avec un caleçon oui peut-être non
peut-être que vous mieux peut-être
qu'avec et qu'elle soit voilà peut-être
pu mettre des petits pois et demandent
si les dames préférerait pas justement
que oui l'envié est là pas par exemple
moi je suis un vieux puis je ne vois pas
quel devant une caméra et des millions
de spectateurs je pense à mes enfants et
mes petits enfants si vous voyez afin
qu'il ya qua non d'un film aujourd'hui
nous avons deux papys là oui mais tu as
déjà lors une question aux papilles vous
avez vécu pendant plusieurs années avec
une une merveilleuse très sensuelle
actrice italienne qui s'appelle le round
1 tabally antonelli bon elle était elle
tourne elle a souvent tourné dans des
films qui peu érotique italien où elle
se dénude est assez souvent entre vous
comment vous y avoir un conflit parce
que est ce que le tour est normal
montrer son corps elle voudrait pas le
mien elle est libre mais là il y avait
rien la porte de moi je suis pas un
dictateur quand je suis avec une femme
si elle a envie de faire quelque chose
dans son métier je ne l'aurais jamais
empêché mais pas le conflit avec elle
non sincèrement on n'en est vraiment pas
d'abord quand j'ai de kankan jeu quand
je l'aï connu c'était un petit peu
dénudée dans un film avec moi d'interpol
sur était mal venu de lui dire après
cette scène de dénuement que que
c'est une malédiction
érotique et puis je vais dire aussi page
dédiée aux téléspectateurs parce que ce
ne soit pas plus de rossi dans votre
d'entre eux va être votre manière
d'aider des jeunes comédiens à monter
des pièces de théâtre et ça vous n'en
parlait jamais non je pense qu'il ya des
choses dans la vie qui a à peine de
sortir les trompettes pour l'annoncer
mais c'est très beau c'est bien alors on
termine pas questionnaire oui votre mot
préféré
variété le scalpel le nom de votre
théâtre
entre autres le mot que vous détestez le
mot que
je déteste vous dire
vivisection votre drogue favorite le
terrain le son le bruit que vous aimez à
l'aller les les jeux audiovisuelle
dans le souhait bossu que vous aimez la
à que j'aime est allé les trois coups
quand ça fait pas en parlant sans le
bruit que vous détestez c'est déjà assez
léger
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori en
avoir oui on était hier l'un qui revient
il est très très démodé c'est
saperlipopette hausse au point un gros
mot salle était sapeur l'ubs on peut
quand les gens qui savent si vous dites
par ses adhérents banlieue à quelqu'un
saperlipopette
ça devient tard c'est démodé savons
c'est ça homme ou femme pour illustrer
un nouveau billet de banque michel
audiard avec sa casquette le métier vous
n'auriez pas aimé faire politiciens la
plante l'arbre l'animal dans lequel vous
aimeriez être réincarné l'animal le
yorkshire le yorkshire c'est évidemment
rien alors il est pas là dessous là elle
dort dans la loge mais où elle regarde
la télé je lui ai parlé de ça et enfin
si dieu existe ça c'est une question
très sérieux site du existe qu aimeriez
vous après votre mort longtemps que vous
dire à vous jean paul belmondo et bien
écoutez moi je suis un optimiste
j'aimerais qu'il dise et qu'on était
bien sûr tromper descendez
merci alors je signale que vous pouvez
vous procurer soul en savoir plus sur
belmondo sculpteur réalisateur gens des
villes celles
c'est une belle production qui présente
donc c'est un film sur lui et puis cette
statue nous a été prêtée par le musée
des des années 30 qui vient de s'ouvrir
à boulogne billancourt et dont vous êtes
le parrain et d'autres pas une
exposition itinérante de jean paul ii
parle paul belmondo qui est actuellement
au musée de roubaix alors on peut
retrouver et est en ce moment à léo au
puy du fou
non mais c'est pas ça mais c'est que là
on passe au 17 décembre est
alors né à roubaix
c'est à roubaix
[Rires]
alors le musée des années 30 voici le
voici de catalogue aux éditions somogy
et puis ça c'est paul belmondo la
sculpture saurait nos éditions somogy
est exactement est aussi alors là il ya
beaucoup de livres sur le cinéma et il
ya beaucoup de godard ça c'est jean luc
godard en deux volumes d'eau aux cahiers
du cinéma c'est tout tous les textes de
godard tous ces propos tout ce qu'il a
écrit depuis depuis 1950 et en deux
volumes et ça c'est l'histoire du cinéma
c'est d'histoire vous les avez vu ces
films histoire du cinéma de jean luc
godard
conjointement par gallimard et gaumont
et c'est une histoire c'est l'histoire
du cinéma vu par godard et c'est assez
je trouve ça d'ailleurs malheureusement
je n'ai pas vu au cinéma mais ça me
donne envie d'aller voir parce que ça
c'est fascinant à lire c'est très
illustré et puis l'année du cinéma
1998 aux éditions calmann lévy je
signale d'autre part ça je vous donnais
salaires l'agenda 1999 des cahiers du
cinéma
comme lui ils n'ont pas dû toujours dire
du bien de vous elle terre du boulevard
ciel mon mari a je vous donnais ce livre
parce que vous qui était un maître de
boxe bat eduardo arroyo panama à lebron
ça c'est une reddition de son lit qui
est paru il ya peut-être quinze ans chez
grasset ça c'est un très très bon livre
pour qui aime la boxe et lebron était un
rbe et un son marqueur le
un dictionnaire de l'ascension du cinéma
de jean luc douin aux presses
universitaires de france et puis le
dernier livre des bruits chevet hier à
vous de jouer des entretiens avec jean
jacques lafaye quelques albums je vais
vite chaplin la grande histoire aux
éditions jean michel place par christian
delage
alors un merveilleux livre mais alors là
vraiment formidable c'est un mickey son
mickey soit la géniale souris c'est pas
un chien c'est une souris génial mais il
ya tout là dedans il ya toutes les
maquettes ou les dessins toutes les
approches toute son évolution du
personnage csu échange des cahiers
décidément contre mikhail non non david
lynch david lynch pas aux cahiers du
cinéma aussi les années ben je vous
donne ça les années bluey sens le cinéma
qu'on aime de 1941 1952 par jean charles
tacchella et roger thérond aux éditions
philippe à qui vous voulez pas devin il
y
aller vous le voulez aller à berlin
allait patrick brion la comédie
américaine patrick millot fin d'album
toujours c'est toujours travailler nos
éditions de mardi et sassi a consacré sa
dernière livraison à la comédie
américaine
le dac chez et la rousse in extenso de
c'est tout sur le théâtre une
encyclopédie théâtre par michel corvin
en deux volumes la réédition du
dictionnaire mondial des films de
bernard rapp et jean claude lamy des
éditions donc en revue et comment est
augmentée mais entendu puisqu'on voit
on voit des dicaprio en couverture ces
dictionnaires donc mondial des films
chez larousse et puis je signale que
très bonne initiative 18 pièces de
molière qui sont montés par la comédie
française et qui sont captés par par
france 3 qui seront diffusées par france
3 même si c'est un peu tardif lord
diffusion faut saluer cette initiative
voici les trois premières pièces qui
viennent de sortir vous pouvez donc vous
procurer les femmes savantes les
précieuses ridicules précieuses
ridicules pardon est ardue merci va
coûter vie 1 0 vive frédéric lemaître
avec jean paul belmondo merci d'être
venus et c'était la dernière émission de
cette année je vous souhaite de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année et l année
prochaine bonsoir à tous
[Musique]